welcome back to new rockstars it's me mt
and have no fear peace is here because
christopher smith is back on peacemaking
patrol on hbo max despite you know
having a nazi science tower fall on the
entirety of his body which you know
sounds like a real pain in the neck
somehow even more of a pain in the neck
than actually being shot in the neck by
bloodsport at the end of the suicide
squad and these three episodes have some
really fun easter eggs and references to
some extremely unique and exciting dc
characters and stuff so let's all just
dive into it together by nerd babies
because peace waits for no one and since
this peacemaker program is a lot more
adult and therefore a lot more dirtier
than your average superhero show you
just gotta start it off with some good
old clean fun in the form of mopping we
immediately get another shot of a mob to
the ground much like james gunn started
off the suicide squad movie with idris
elba's bloodsport cleaning up belle reef
prison and also on the ground where the
mop lands you can see red blue and
yellow stripes on the ground which are
of course the colors of christopher
chromedome's costume and when peacemaker
is gathering his stuff on his way out of
the hospital you can see a piece of
paper that peacemaker used to remember
all of his teammates names in the
suicide squad amongst other portal
maltese souvenirs apparently referring
to a rat catcher as kid abner krills the
polka dot man as polka dots bloodsport
as black guy which you know he's out of
line but he's right along with
peacemaker's best attempt at spelling
king shark's name nanawe but there's
also something really interesting in the
form of a phone number for a person
named valentina who i'm assuming to be a
reference to the character of valentina
vostok a russian dc character by the
name of negative woman who has teamed up
with peacemaker and vigilante in the
past and could very well appear later on
in the show and after breaking into his
own home peacemaker is of course met by
the task force x team consisting of the
die hard steve ages john economos a tech
in the show but the warden of bel
reeve's prison in the comics jennifer
hollins emilia harcourt peacemaker's
handler but also a task force x double
agent in the comics which is interesting
along with chukwudi iwuji's clemson mirn
and daniel brooks lyoda adebayo who are
both original creations for the show
with the wuji being set to play the
villain in james gunn's next comic book
project guardians of the galaxy vol 3.
who james gunn cast today in the role
after witnessing awuji's amazing talent
first hand in the peacemaker show and of
course it is later revealed that lyoda
adebayo is actually the daughter of
amanda waller herself tasked with
keeping an eye on peacemaker mirn and
the rest of the team and hiring family
is something that amanda waller is prone
to do as the character flo crawley from
the suicide squad film you know the lady
who bopped waller's noggin towards the
end of the movie in the comics flo is a
cousin of amanda wallers and if that is
true in the dc eu leota adebayo could
have been chosen by amanda waller to be
the replacement for flo after flo hit
her in the head knowing amanda waller
probably not looking good for club well
it's probably not alive an infowars
parody called fact attack plays in the
home of peacemakers racist of a father
when chris arrives to get a new helmet
and acts as a clever piece of
foreshadowing for the show's events as a
crazy alex jone parody says
below their
lying liberal human faces learned
extraterrestrial beings who want nothing
other than our civilization to fail
which of course actually ends up turning
out to be true as the extraterrestrial
butterflies of project butterfly have
been embedding themselves in the dceu
secret invasion style and also
apparently much like ratcatcher 2 in the
suicide squad movie peacemaker seems to
be a title christopher inherited from
his dad who apparently had a massive
arsenal of high-tech helmets which i
screamed about because i was praying
that we were gonna get some really weird
helmet abilities like peacemaker has in
the original comics and good god did the
man james gunn deliver i did not wake up
on thursday thinking that i would see a
grown woman blown up by a prison toilet
bowl helmet but here we are today me a
better man
[Laughter]
as the world's premier service for
horror thriller and supernatural content
shudder is a necessity for fans of
thrills and chills sign up for shutter
and get access to the largest collection
of binge-worthy horror movies in series
streamed right to your favorite devices
shutter gives you unlimited access to
the largest fastest growing human
curated selection of thrilling and
dangerous entertainment ad free for just
5.99 a month new shockers and thrillers
get added every week and shutter works
on your smart tv xbox one apple tv or
any other device what we really like
about shutter is that they not only have
the horror classics like halloween or
phantasm but also a ton of new original
and foreign films you should watch a
girl walks home alone at night trust me
it's really good and it's a great time
to check out shutter's great collection
of folk or get rural and creepy with
classics like the wicker man and texas
chainsaw massacre or some deeper cuts
like kill list and the wailing they also
have an exclusive documentary woodlands
dark and days bewitched a history of
folk horror to get started streaming the
best horror thriller and supernatural
content to try shutter for free for 30
days go to shutter.com and use promo
code new rockstars that's
s-h-u-d-d-e-r-dot-com
[Music]
and use promo code new rockstars for a
free 30-day trial and in addition to
comic peacemaker's voice changing laser
shooting helmet he also possessed a jet
pack which is why peacemaker brought up
loving jetpacks earlier in the episode
can i get a jet pack no and of course
the wayne foundation logo can be found
right on the center of peacemaker's
diary which makes sense considering the
wayne family's reputation as
philanthropists pushing for peace and in
episode 2 we of course learned that
peacemaker's father august ransom smith
was secretly famed dc racist the white
dragon the entire time a racist
supervillain in the comics named william
heller who did exactly what peacemaker's
dad did and targeted mainly minorities
doing crimes and not really the whites
all that much during william heller's
days as the vigilante known as william
hell before fully becoming the armored
white dragon teaming up with other dc
neo-nazis and eventually being recruited
by amanda waller's task force x and of
course i cannot talk about this
breakdown without acknowledging how the
man james gunn finally brought the
beloved wacky character batmite into the
dceu cannon by john economos confirming
task force x's knowledge of his
existence i'd rather be with
batmite than you who's badmind the two
foot tall interdimensional imp who
stands batman a character that james
gunn originally wanted to try to include
in the original suicide squad movie
until you know for some reason he just
didn't work out which is a super
exciting easter egg for us but probably
not so much for the homunculi hate and
beast makers and speaking of a monkey
life the dc hero doll man one of dc's
first ever shrinking heroes gets a shout
out by peacemaker at the very start of
episode 3 as well hey doll man you ever
meet him dumb man he turns small
he calls himself dolman yeah also in
episode 2 amber's spineless boyfriend
with zero tasted music can be seen
walking around with the same a mouse on
his shirt that james gunn's team
designed for rick flagg in the suicide
squad movie and finally we cannot wrap
this video up without talking about
project butterfly which appears to be
dceu's super awesome way of setting up
their upcoming blue beetle project and i
say this because the scarab technology
that powers the hero blue beetle suit in
the comics was developed by an alien
race known as the reach who have been
known to drop these technologically
advanced scarabs on planets that latch
onto a random host and completely
rewrites their personality you know kind
of like we saw with peacemaker's booty
call in episode one and senator goff in
episode three which means that that
piece of alien technology that opened up
for peacemaker after amber did for both
peacemaker and vigilante is likely
reached technology maybe even a scarab
itself but who knows but that was just a
quick rundown of all the important
easter eggs from the first three
episodes of peacemaker what'd you guys
think of the premiere i thought it was
awesome but what did you guys think let
us know in the comment section below but
anyways thank you guys so much for
watching this video you can follow me at
mastertainment if you want to see me
tweet some really weird [ __ ] and cool
theories but more importantly you can
follow new rockstars wherever we are on
social media and on youtube but when you
do on youtube make sure you hit that
notification bell so you get
notifications whenever we upload a video
and of course hit up new rockstars
birch.com you get cool shirts like this
and also enough our discord if you want
to continue the new rockstars
conversation but please make sure that
you are 18 years old because we're
adults here in the rock stars so we talk
about adult stuff like uh threesomes
with a stranger that you just met um in
episode two of peacemaker who's going
through a lot of relationship troubles
but ultimately just couldn't work it out
and decided to have a threesome with two
serial killers anyway bye
[Music]
you